[Musique]
par ses danses et subjectif sélectif est
incomplet vous verrez ça raconte quand
même quelque chose
40 ans toujours puceau de judd apatow
l'avènement d'une comédie américaine
grinçant intelligent délicieusement
adulescents les fils de l'homme
d'alfonso warhol ou de science-fiction
sombre et splendide qui annonçait déjà
les éclats à venir du cinéaste mexicain
quand j'étais chanteur de xavier
giannoli la rencontre entre cécile de
france et gérard depardieu dans un bal
populaire est un hommage à la chanson
française canine de yorgos lanthimos
deuxième film du cinéaste grec de
l'absurde de la communauté son premier
succès international
[Musique]
les amours imaginaires de xavier dolan
est le deuxième long métrage du prodige
canadien prix de la jeunesse au festival
de cannes doit une lyrique sur la
passion amoureuse
tomboy de céline sciamma révélation de
la cinéaste française
un film qui interroge le jour qui a nou
sé nombre de questionnements et de
changement intouchable d'eric toledano
et olivier nakache le plus grand succès
commercial du cinéma français par le
tandem roi de la comédie
omar sy devint une star internationale
une séparation d'asghar farhadi avec son
cinquième film le cinéaste iranien
décroche l'ours d'or à berlin
l'oscar le golden globe et le césar du
meilleur film étranger mode sur les
rives du mississippi de jeff nichols le
troisième film de jeff nichols signate
de l'amérique profonde
l'un des héritiers de terrence malick et
de steven spielberg
l'inconnue du laki et d'alain guiraudie
ou de poker gagnant pour alain guiraudie
est improductif il dit pialat avec ce
thriller gay très déshabillée
révélations de pierre de la bouche en
victoria de justin trièves justin tri
mais qui invente une nouvelle manière de
montrer la société française avec deux
acteurs qu'on aime
virginie efira et vincent lacoste tony
herman de marena de la révélation
cannoise du cinéaste allemande au regard
à la fois tendre et implacable grave de
julia ducournau avec le premier film de
cet élève de l'athéisme cinéma de genre
qu'on s'aime outre ces dos et il a très
très bel appétit faute d'amour d'andreï
zviaguintsev suivant
primé au festival de cannes le
réalisateur russe a reposé en cinq films
ce cinéma minérale est désespérée
heureux comme lazzaro daiichi rohr
vainqueur 3 kim deux prix à cannes pour
la jeune italienne et ce cinéma inventif
presque expérimental parfois je vous
avais prévu on n'a pas pu tout citer
tout le monde mais on pense bien sûr
aussi à maïwenn à greta garbo il parle
aux sorties no matteo garrone luca
guadagnino bertrand mandico anton
intéressante qu felix van groeningen
mais quelle roskam chuck baker yann
gonzales barry jenkins damien chazelle
denis villeneuve
mais s'il fallait citer un seul titre un
seul film celui qui vous a le plus
marqué pendant ses 15 saisons
même parmi les oeuvres de réalisateurs
plus chevronnés frédéric hostyn cinéaste
sait les hauts de hurlevent d'andrea
arnold oui plus belles adaptations
littéraires que j'ai vu depuis très
longtemps et puis surtout une cinéaste
qui invente un langage qui est toujours
en train de se renouveler qui a changé
je crois quelque chose dans l'histoire
du cinéma et surtout et quelque chose
c'est que je crois qu'elle a vraiment
digéré l mieux que d'autres
l' influence de terrence malick c'est
d'autant plus intéressant sur les hauts
de hurlevent qui a été mis à l'écran
plusieurs fois et pas forcément pour le
meilleur
on se souvient du film de william wyler
dac notamment lille i blue moves bresse
et under the skin de johnatan kaiser
avec scarlett johansson en alien qui ait
frappé que deux d'humanité comme d'une
maladie c'est un film qui pour moi
questionne le cinéma qui qui qui m'a
bouleversé d'ondés des séquences
entières me sont restées en mémoire et
qui était inquiète à voir voilà qu'il y
ferait pour moi sera melancholia lars
von triers qui se réinvente dans ses 15
ans on le connaissait d'avant et qui
arrive avec un film monde qui raconte la
fin du monde et qui à mon avis rejoint
les 15 qu'on a vue là c'est à dire que
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya une explosion
du cinéma de genre et que finalement il
ya plus le seimat genre le cinéma
d'auteur et que les auteurs vont
emprunter à des gens pour faire des
oeuvres qui leur sont propres et qui
explosent le cadre du symat jambes et
c'est le cas de mélancolie art peut pas
dire que c'est un film catastrophe c'est
un film de lars von trier marie sauvion
alors moi j'ai choisi mademoiselle de
park chan wook projection idyllique à
cannes en 2016 je découvre ce film
j'aimais beaucoup park chan wook déjà
all boys et et plein d'autres films et
leurs là en fait je me rends compte
pourquoi ce film là m'est venue très
spontanément il est
à l'exact conjonction de tout ce qui
m'intéresse au cinéma c'est à dire que
visuellement c'est un enchantement une
perfection moi je voudrais vivre dedans
je voudrais ses décors ses papiers
peints ses costumes ses gants pour tous
m'enchante
ils sont bons on voudrait se fondre là
dedans et en même temps oui nous
attendait là même qui est à la fois
extrêmement drôle extrêmement
passionnant très audacieux en chapitres
comme ça qui se joue du spectateur qui
nous une complicité c'est quoi c'est une
dénonciation implacable de la domination
du colonialisme et du patriarcat et
c'est l'histoire l'émancipation de deux
femmes qui avait tout pour être des
victimes
c'est une merveille à 20k mauvais c'est
un portrait de femme mais côté américain
c'est noah baumbach française a en 2012
je suis ce réalisateur depuis 2005 et
les berkman se séparent alors pourquoi
ce signe pourquoi prendre ça ça parce
que c'est une comédie dramatique libre
inspiré légère et en même temps
complètement névrosé ça se passe à new
york et cette ville évidemment le noir
et blanc lui va si bien je ne vous
l'apprends pas il ya des clins d'oeil
partout à woody allen voilà ça j'y ai
trouvé forcément une forme d'héritage
et puis greta garbo wii qui était blue
ils sentent dans le film qui a des rêves
tellement grand qu'il finisse par être
encombrant voilà c'est un magnifique
portrait au film et non loin des clichés
et un bonheur n'arrivant jamais seul il
ya aussi adam driver dans le film qui
est un de mes petits chouchous
mais on ajoute aussi des cinéastes qui
ont pris leur envol avant la naissance
du cercle qui sont tellement épanouie
ces dernières années je pense à jacques
audiard je pense abdellatif kechiche à
michael haneke
alejandro conzalez inarritu lynne ramsey
les frères safdie wes anderson
nuri bilge ceylan nicholas winding refn
merci à eux pour toutes ces années pour
tous ces moments de plaisir
[Applaudissements]